the introduction of IBM Security qradar
Suite updates from IBM storage and IBM
Cloud projects and cost estimation all
on this episode of IBM Tech now what's
up y'all my name is Ian and I am back to
bring you the latest and greatest news
and announcements about IBM technology
jumping right in we are excited to
introduce IBM Security qradar Suite A
major Evolution and expansion of the
qradar brand that spans all core threat
detection investigation and response
Technologies
with qradar Suite IBM has re-architected
its market-leading threat detection and
response portfolio around the following
core design principles and capabilities
first is a unified analyst experience
including a common modernized user
interface that empowers analysts to work
more quickly and efficiently throughout
their investigation and response
processes second is cloud delivery speed
and scale delivered as a service on AWS
qradar Suite products allow for
simplified deployment across Cloud
environments and integration with public
cloud and SAS log data and third is open
platform and out of the box Integrations
the suite brings together the core
Technologies needed in today's security
operations centers and is built on an
open platform it also has a wide partner
ecosystem with more than 900 pre-built
Integrations for flexibility and choice
across IBM and third-party products
to learn more about IBM security curator
suite and the products that it includes
check the link in the description of
this video
next up let's look at some exciting IBM
storage updates as we continue to focus
on bringing Innovation to our IBM
storage for data resiliency portfolio
IBM flash system is a key component of
this portfolio and it handles some of
the most challenging application and
data workloads we are now introducing
inline corruption detection that uses Ai
and machine learning services to detect
data changes that can be indicative of
threats or direct attacks on your data
sets in near real time
we're also introducing standard flash
system configurations that are modeled
against the most prevalent workloads
that you need
this will simplify your storage
configuration to three simple choices
storage controller performance and
capacity the number of drives and the
size of each Drive
finally we're also excited to announce
that we are offering a reduction of
Select flash system list prices by 15
globally through June 30th 2023.
to learn more and take advantage of
these savings hit the link below
to wrap things up today I want to take a
look at the release of IBM Cloud
projects and cost estimation projects
are a named collection of configurations
that are used to manage related
resources and infrastructure as code
deployments across accounts
the cost estimator is a platform service
that provides cost estimates for
terraform-based products
together IBM Cloud projects and cost
estimation helps Enterprises
significantly reduce time spent managing
and monitoring resources ensure a secure
by default environment for critical
workloads maintain continuous compliance
across the cloud and ensure application
and infrastructure security and
compliance to learn more and get started
check out the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now